[Aplausos]
[Música]
puerto rico no gana para disgustos si no
fuera suficiente con la salvaje crisis
económica que padece desde hace ya más
de una década su declaración de
bancarrota los huracanes y mariah que en
el 2017 arrasaron la isla ahora además
se suman los terremotos más de 2000
movimientos sísmicos registrados que
comenzaron en 2019 y que se están
prolongando durante el 2020 vamos que ya
no sé qué más le puede pasar a la isla
suerte lo que se dice suerte pues
precisamente no están teniendo ahora
bien con todo lo que más llama la
atención es que en ocasiones este lugar
parece más un territorio del áfrica
subsahariana que de los mismísimos eeuu
un momento que por qué digo tal cosa
fijaos
el huracán maría causó un enorme caos
del que la isla más de dos años después
aún no se ha recuperado y ojo porque no
sólo hablamos de las más de tres mil
vidas perdidas el huracán dejó la isla
sin electricidad durante semanas e
incluso en algunas zonas la electricidad
no se restableció hasta pasados 11 meses
destruyó más de 90 mil casas y los daños
a las infraestructuras fueron enormes
y vamos a ver seamos honestos que un
huracán cause daños es algo que entra
dentro de lo previsible que las
consecuencias tarden años en arreglarse
y el caos se ha generalizado eso ya no
es algo tan normal al menos no debería
serlo en un territorio que pertenece a
los mismísimos eeuu no os parece
y ojo que estamos hablando en algunos
casos de casi un año sin electricidad un
año que esas cosas pasen en el tercer
mundo pues se entiende pero en eeuu de
verdad de locos
el caso amigos es que toda esta
destrucción llegó por si fuera poco en
un momento particularmente difícil para
puerto rico como ya os contamos en un
vídeo que os dejo la descripción apenas
un par de años antes en el 2015 el
gobierno de la isla se había declarado
en bancarrota y la situación económica
era mala muy mala y luego para colmo te
viene no uno sino dos huracanes
y eso es precisamente de lo que os vamos
a hablar en este vídeo de cómo es el
puerto rico- post maría de cómo se
afrontó la situación y de qué futuro
podemos esperar para una isla que está
atravesando el que tal vez es el peor
momento de su historia reciente
atentos
el rastro de mariah más allá de las
cifras
dos huracanes enormes en menos de un mes
primero el huracán irma que golpeó a la
isla de perfil y más tarde el huracán
maría que lo golpeó de lleno algo así
como el rancho final a un boxeador que
estaba a punto del caos
ahora bien como todos sabéis puerto rico
es una isla caribeña es decir está muy
expuesta a este tipo de fenómenos y es
normal que los huracanes causen daños
eso está claro la cuestión es que
teniendo en cuenta su renta per cápita y
su nivel de desarrollo la isla sufrió
consecuencias mucho pero que mucho
mayores de las que debería de haber
sufrido
y la pregunta que nos tenemos que hacer
es por qué demonios estos huracanes
causaron tantos daños no estaba acaso
preparado puerto rico- para hacer frente
a contingencias de este tipo porque se
tardó tanto en reparar los deterioros y
eso cuando los arreglaron en definitiva
querían tres pasa con puerto rico
esa es amigos es la pregunta para
entender mejor lo que ocurre en esta
isla podemos echar un vistazo a lo que
ocurrió con el sistema eléctrico tras el
paso del huracán maría que una zona
concreta de un territorio se quede sin
electricidad tras el paso de un huracán
es algo comprensible y hasta cierto
punto normal sin embargo que se quede
sin electricidad una isla entera del
tamaño de puerto rico- con más de tres
millones de habitantes eso eso ya es muy
distinto
es algo que nos da ciertas pistas acerca
de que las cosas no marchaban
precisamente bien antes del huracán y lo
cierto es que exactamente por ahí van
los tiros la infraestructura eléctrica
puertorriqueña se encontraba en una
situación desastrosa más propio de un
país del tercer mundo pero nunca de un
estado libre asociado de los eeuu
de esta forma debido a la mala previsión
y sobre todo al mal mantenimiento la
tempestad tumbo al menos una cuarta
parte de las torres de transmisión
eléctrica e inutilizó el 40% de las
subestaciones el resultado fue la más
absoluta oscuridad
y es que para colmo los sistemas de
producción eléctrica y los principales
centros de consumo están en lados
opuestos de la isla me explico mientras
el 70% de las centrales fósiles se
encuentran en la zona sur el 70% de la
demanda se concentra en la zona
y precisamente esa distribución exige
que las conexiones estén bien protegidas
algo que como veis no tenía nada pero
que nada que ver con la situación real
de la isla de hecho la propia línea de
alta tensión que conecta los centros de
producción con los centros de consumo
fue destrozada por el paso del huracán
en resumen unos daños enormes exagerado
esta reparación llevó muchísimo tiempo
pero ahora bien puede que llegados a
este punto muchos estéis pensando pero
enrique porque tanta insistencia con el
sistema eléctrico de puerto rico- pues
amigos porque lo que estamos viendo es
algo así como una prueba de esfuerzo un
ejercicio una muestra que nos permite
ver las patologías que realmente se
esconden tras los problemas por los que
atraviesa este lugar
y ojo no solo en puerto rico- también en
otros muchos lugares de latinoamérica
atentos
[Música]
un colapso ha anunciado
amigos lo siento pero es que es la
verdad el sistema eléctrico
puertorriqueño ha sido esencialmente un
sistema público desde los años 40 de
hecho una empresa del gobierno la
autoridad de energía eléctrica tuvo el
monopolio de la distribución y la
producción eléctrica hasta el año 2010
y con mucha diferencia hoy sigue siendo
el actor más importante de la isla y
también un fiel reflejo de todo lo que
ocurre en este lugar no me creéis pues
fijaos en el año 2017 esta empresa
pública monopolística entró en
bancarrota
y mira que es difícil quebrar a una
empresa que tiene el monopolio sobre un
servicio básico pues sí eso es
exactamente lo que pasó el caso es que
lo hizo pocos meses después de la propia
declaración de bancarrota del gobierno
de puerto rico la mayor bancarrota de la
historia de las administraciones
públicas de los eeuu
y amigos las razones de ambas
declaraciones de quiebra fueron
prácticamente las mismas por un lado el
derroche la falta de responsabilidad y
la incompetencia de los políticos
locales hubo un papel esencial no nos
engañemos al final el primer responsable
siempre está en casa
[Música]
pero en esta ocasión no fueron los
únicos en cierto modo ya os lo hemos
contado aquí en visual político en aguas
bancarrotas los eeuu tuvieron buena
parte de la responsabilidad y si lo
habéis escuchado bien los eeuu
torrico huila puesto
ya os lo hemos contado en alguna que
otra ocasión la situación de enorme
precariedad en la que se encuentra
puerto rico- se debe además de al mal
gobierno isleño ya la corrupción al
maltrato legal al que eeuu somete a este
territorio semi colonial en el caso de
la autoridad de energía eléctrica la
bancarrota del 2017 apenas unos meses
antes del paso de irme y mariah se debió
fundamentalmente a la supresión en 1996
de la sección 936 del código de rentas
internas del gobierno federal de eeuu
y que decía esta sección pues
básicamente otorgaba exenciones en los
impuestos federales para las empresas
localizadas en territorio bajo control
de eeuu como puerto rico pues bien en el
caso que nos atañe en el de esta isla
caribeña se estableció un periodo de
gracia de 10 años como transición hasta
la eliminación total de esos incentivos
fiscales proceso que fue culminado en el
año 2005
vale os hago una pregunta qué pensáis
qué pasó después exacto lo habéis
clavado apenas unos meses después está
hay una enorme crisis la huida de puerto
rico- de todo tipo de inversiones
especialmente de las inversiones
industriales fue enorme
para que os hagáis una idea el 60% ojo
el 60 por ciento de los clientes
industriales de la compañía eléctrica se
marcharon de la isla
[Música]
por supuesto esto hizo que el desempleo
la economía informal y la pobreza
crecieran como la espuma y todo este
cóctel combinado hundió el consumo
eléctrico algo que a su vez cause un
enorme deterioro en las cuentas de la
empresa pública de electricidad
[Música]
y claro si su gestión ya era peor que
mala ahora como veis tenían que lidiar
además con una enorme caída de ingresos
un agujero de proporciones épicas
[Música]
de esta forma la autoridad de energía
eléctrica no sólo empezó a devorar
enormes cantidades de deuda sino que
cualquier plan de modernización
transformación e incluso mantenimiento
no urgente quedó aparcado de hecho la
empresa tuvo que aplicar incluso
recortes en las tareas de mantenimiento
ordinarias y aún así nada fue suficiente
para evitar que 10 años después se
declarara en quiebra
es decir para que nos entendamos
hablamos de una empresa que fue hundida
por la gestión de los políticos
portorriqueños y también por las
decisiones de los políticos de
washington un cóctel explosivo
y eso mismo es lo que ha pasado
exactamente en toda la isla tal vez que
los puertorriqueños no tengan ni voz ni
voto las elecciones de los eeuu tenga
algo que ver y no no me contéis la
milonga de que eligen una especie de
portavoz para que les represente en el
congreso no os engañéis si no tiene voto
no cuenta
amigos puerto rico salgo así como un
territorio completamente olvidado por
los eeuu a pesar de que formalmente es
eeuu o mejor dicho está bajo el dominio
de la superpotencia norteamericana
lo que sí parece claro es que los
políticos de washington no se fían nada
pero que nada de los políticos
puertorriqueños vale dado los
antecedentes de corrupción el mal uso de
los fondos públicos y su pésima gestión
pues es algo comprensible pero es que
tampoco hacen mucho por no decir nada
para cambiar la situación
[Música]
una prueba de toda esta enorme
desconfianza la pudimos ver tras el
impacto del huracán maría en ese momento
el congreso de los eeuu entonces de
mayoría republicana y de acuerdo en todo
momento con la administración trump
obligó a puerto rico- a crear un plan de
reconstrucción que sería estrechamente
fiscalizado por la junta de supervisión
fiscal un organismo federal creado tras
la declaración de bancarrota de la isla
para controlar las cuentas del gobierno
pero no contentos con esto además
impusieron una serie de normas muy
exigentes y prácticamente sin
precedentes por ejemplo todo contrato
superior a los 10 millones de dólares
para la reconstrucción tenía que ser
supervisado minuciosamente por esta
junta algo que puede sonar muy bien pero
que sin embargo en este caso causó un
enorme problema la junta no es
precisamente el organismo más rápido en
llevar a cabo sus tareas es decir lo que
la práctica hizo el congreso fue
burocratizar hasta unos niveles
asfixiantes todas las tareas de
reconstrucción
vamos que lo que podría ser una buena
idea se acabó convirtiendo en un
infierno burocrático puerto rico fue
golpeado por el huracán maría arruinado
por la negligencia de la agencia federal
para el manejo de emergencias y
vilipendiado por trump y ahí ahí no
termina todo otro ejemplo lo tenemos en
los requisitos extraordinarios y sin
precedentes que se le impusieron a la
agencia federal para el manejo de las
emergencias y al departamento de
vivienda y desarrollo urbano es decir a
las dos agencias federales encargadas de
distribuir y gestionar los fondos para
la recuperación en caso de catástrofes
y es que veréis entre otras cosas en
abril del 2018 el gobierno federal le
impuso estas agencias un límite de gasto
que no podía ser superior en ningún caso
a la estimación de costes que hiciera el
propio gobierno de puerto rico para la
reconstrucción es decir se querían
evitar a toda costa los sobrecostes
de esta forma si durante el proceso
aparecían imprevistos o situaciones
inesperadas puedes ajo y agua que se
dice en españa puerto rico tendría que
aguantarse
y seguro que esto a muchos os puede
parecer muy bien verdad al menos hasta
que caes en la cuenta de que es toda una
invitación a sobrevalorar los daños e
inflar los presupuestos de
reconstrucción que es exactamente lo que
hizo el gobierno de puerto rico pero eso
eso nos llevaría a un debate que
necesitaría varios vídeos el caso amigos
es que tal y como veis durante todo el
proceso dio la sensación de que el
gobierno federal estaba mucho más
preocupado por controlar a los políticos
portorriqueños que de la propia
reconstrucción de la isla
ahora bien se les puede culpar por ello
aunque demonio se debe tanta
desconfianza atentos
[Música]
puerto rico de mal en peor por supuesto
los problemas de puerto rico- no sólo
provienen de las leyes federales que si
vale son incapaces de adaptarse a la
realidad puertorriqueña pero decir tal
cosa sería faltar a la verdad lo cierto
es que durante muchos años los gobiernos
isleños han pasado olímpicamente de los
gravísimos problemas financieros que
tenían la isla y se dedicaron pues
básicamente a pedir más y más y más
dinero al congreso de los eeuu los
propios huracanes nos dejaron alguna
muestra de la más absoluta falta de
capacidad queréis un ejemplo pues fijaos
en lo que pasó en la semana siguientes a
la catástrofe en puerto rico-
contenedores llenos de mercancías
permanecen en los puertos sin ser
distribuidos y amigos no penséis ni por
un instante que hablamos de casos
aislados para nada de hecho hace muy
poco tiempo prácticamente anteayer a
comienzos del 2020 se descubrió en un
almacén numerosos palés de ayuda
humanitaria del huracán maría que no
habían sido distribuidos por supuesto
con comida caducada el director de
emergencias de puerto rico- es despedido
después de que residentes descubrieran
un almacén lleno de suministros del
huracán maría y no es la primera vez
de hecho esta incapacidad para lidiar
con los problemas y las sospechas
constantes de corrupción pues son la
tónica habitual el resultado de todo
ello es que aún hoy en una parte de los
eeuu muchas casas siguen dañadas y
muchos tejados siguen cubiertos por
toldos azules así que con semejante
panorama seguro seguro que nos extraña
saber que la dura crisis que comenzó en
2016 continúa hoy en día que las cuentas
públicas del gobierno siguen
prácticamente tan mal como cuando se
declaró en quiebra de hecho más que
necesitaron auditor o un contable y
necesitan un taxidermista
y que el éxodo de puertorriqueños hacia
eeuu ha reducido la población en más de
600.000 personas desde el año 2004 y
todo esto es lo que explica que entre
unas cosas y otras la isla se esté
viniendo abajo lo ocurrido con la
empresa de energía eléctrica es un buen
reflejo de lo que acontece en todo este
territorio pero llegados a este punto la
pregunta que podemos que tenemos que
hacernos es cómo puede puerto rico-
salir de esta amigos personalmente lo
tengo claro eeuu tiene que dejar de una
vez por todas a un lado el paternalismo
y permitir que este territorio se
gestione con total autonomía para bien o
para mal al menos de esa forma los
políticos locales pues no tendrían
escusas mientras tanto en cualquier plan
de ajuste no valdrá para muchos si es
que llegaban el par algo al fin y al
cabo si no cambian los nombres del
modelo no van a cambiar los resultados
no nos engañéis no van a cambiar los
resultados pero qué pensáis vosotros
como creéis que puerto rico puede
escapar de esta difícil situación si os
parece podéis dejar vuestra opinión en
los comentarios y abrimos debate y ya
sabéis si este vídeo se resultó
interesante no dejéis de darle al botón
de like una vez más muchas gracias por
estar ahí un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]